uh we have new video from another one of
these school board meetings this one
took place yesterday why is it always
Florida this one was in Seminole County
Florida
I have two clips here to play for you in
this first clip a guy who shows up says
that vaccines are a deep state
conspiracy to depopulate the world and
this is the most listen to this the most
fascinating element of this is this guy
says
you can't even learn this stuff from Fox
News anymore he is too radical for Fox
News Fox News isn't giving him what he
wants anymore he's telling you the truth
you won't get it on Fox News because Fox
News and Hannity have been compromised
let's listen together
[Applause]
deep populate I know you guys think
that's a conspiracy theory but it's not
it's a conspiracy
factoots with each other to depopulate
us they want us divided they want all of
us to fight each other so they can win
this is good now what would be the like
of course this doesn't pass the sniff
test but what would be the point of a
mass depopulation right I mean the the
centers of power if ultimately money is
their motivation you get money from
people who buy goods and services at the
end of the day that's what it is and
that could be by Health Care Services or
that could be byproducts or consume
streaming or whatever it is what on
Earth would cause the centers of power
to want to depopulate anyway like it
doesn't even pass the sniff test versus
evil Evil's not going to Prevail all
you've done is awaken the sleeping giant
here every parent here the language is
of course of delusions of grandeur and
incredible self aggrandizement Freedom
except maybe some of them that are
brainwashed by the Deep State media I
used to watch Fox News deliberately I'm
a conservative I won't even watch that
now because did you did he need to tell
us he's a conservative but listen to
what he says about Fox Hannity
[Applause]
10 penny is that complete and total
lunatic who was talking about the
vaccine magnetizing you and and some
other things what do we do about this do
the I'm all for public comment periods
school boards are unable to get anything
done because of these comment periods
and these outrageous conspiracy
theorists that are showing up who tell
us they'll they'll Fox News is too Fox
News won't tell you the truth they've
been compromised but 10 Penny will tell
you the truth and there's a mass
depopulation plan
what are we do we need to end the public
comment periods one more clip from this
same meeting here's a woman who went to
the same Seminole County school board
meeting and she talks about she hits all
the she's doing Ivermectin she's
bringing back Bill Gates
um it it's unbelievable
Fast Pro Masters are touting death rates
in hospitals as excuses to mass kids
have they looked into what's really
causing these deaths Hospital protocols
the crowd is cheering that what people
are dying from isn't covered
it's Hospital protocol
[Applause]
and infusions in hospitals I ever met an
hcqy because it's not accepted by the
National Institute of Health why drugs
these drugs have been around for years
and have been used worldwide why won't
they use them here's the key now
remember those things have been peer
reviewed there have been rcts and they
show no statistically significant effect
on covid the fact that a drug has been
approved for something else doesn't tell
us whether it's effective for covid this
is it's part of the the disinformation
that they rely on or the money
thank you in fact it's actually the
opposite they say there's money there's
more money to be you wouldn't make money
using Ivermectin or hydroxychloroquine
actually the reason as we talked about
this with Vincent rack and yellow
yesterday the reason these drugs start
to be tested is because they are so
cheap and they're just sitting around
and doctors say I've got nothing else
for it let me try it it's it's the
reverse causality of what these people
are talking about it is what we need to
do okay and it's it's cheap I ever met
this is cheap why doesn't it work wink
wink Follow Me Now
no agencies like the CDC and the FDA do
not work for the American taxpayers they
are non-profit corporations
for companies politicians and
individuals like Bill Gates for years
ethics can
for years ethic complaints have been
lodged against these agencies for the
Cozy relationships between them and the
companies they are supposed to register
so it's always some kind of conspiracy
so what do we do is it time to end the
public comment periods is it time to
what what I mean I don't know what to do
my instinct is never to suppress speech
I'm all about public comment periods at
city council school boards Etc but this
is a nationwide epidemic
of these school board meetings just
being taken over by these people I don't
know how it should be handled let me
know what you think you can find me on
Twitter at dpacman one of our sponsors
is sheath underwear it's summer right
now in the northern hemisphere it's hot
it's humid many of the men in my
audience know about the discomfort that
can come with this with traditional
underwear the sweating the chafing the
sticking not fun and that's what sheath
underwear has solved sheath has designed
men's boxer briefs with multiple
ergonomic compartments built into the
front of the underwear which keeps
everything separate dry cool and
comfortable all day long sheath has
re-released to limited edition Styles
Flower of Life with a stylish flower
pattern and bold geometric waistband the
other limited edition style is the mesh
airflow especially designed to be
lightweight and promote extra coolness
and breathability give sheath underwear
a try I've had a great experience with
it I think you will too you can find the
link underneath this video and don't
forget to use promo code Pacman for 20
off